YUFENG GUO: In this
thrilling conclusion
to our video on training
big models in the cloud,
I'll help you scale your compute
power from machine learning.
Will our training
have enough resources?
Stay tuned to find out.
In our previous
episode, we talked
about the problems that are
encountered when your data is
too big to fit on
your local machine,
and we discussed how we can move
that data off onto the cloud
to have scalable storage.
Today, we move on to the
second half of that problem--
getting those compute
resources wrangled together.
When training larger
models, the current approach
involves doing
training in parallel.
What this means is that our
data gets split up and sent
to many worker machines,
And then the model must
put the information
in signals it's
getting back together to
create the fully trained model.
Now, you could spin up
some virtual machines
and install the
network libraries,
network them together,
configure them
to run distributed
machine learning,
and then when you
finish, you'd want
to take down those machines.
While this may
seem easy to some,
it can be a challenge
if you're not
familiar with things like
installing GBU drivers
and debugging
compatibility problems
between different versions
of the underlying libraries.
So today we'll use Cloud Machine
Learning Engine's training
functionality to
go from Python code
to train model with no
infrastructure work needed.
The service automatically
acquires and configures
resources as needed
and shuts them down
when it's done training.
There are three main steps to
using Cloud Machine Learning
Engine--
packaging your Python code,
creating a configuration file
that describes the
kind of machines
you want, and submitting your
training job to the cloud.
Let's see how to
set up our training
to take advantage
of this service.
We've moved our Python code
from our Jupyter notebook
out into a separate
script on its own.
Let's call that file task.py.
This is going to act as our
Python module, which will
be called from other files.
Now, we want to wrap task.py
inside a Python package.
Python packages are made
by placing the module
inside another folder--
let's call it trainer--
and placing an empty file,
__init__.py, alongside test.py.
So our final file structure
is made up of a folder called
trainer containing two files,
the __init__py and the task.py
files.
While our package
is called trainer
our module path is trainer.task.
If you wanted to break out
the code into more components,
you would include those
in this folder as well.
For example, you might
have, say, a util.py
in the trainer folder.
Once our code is
packaged up, it's time
to create a configuration
file to specify what machines
you want running your training.
You can choose to
run your training
with just a small number
of machines, as few as one
or, many machines with
GPUs attached to them.
There are a few predefined
specifications, which
make it easy to get started.
And once you grow
out of those, you
can configure a
custom architecture
to your heart's content.
We've got our Python
code packaged up,
and we have our configuration
file written out.
So let's move on to the step
you've all been waiting for,
the training.
To submit a training job, we'll
use the gcloud command line
tool and run gcloud ml-engine
jobs submit training.
There is also an
equivalent REST API call.
We specify a unique job name,
the package path and module
name, the region for
your job to run in,
and a cloud storage
directory to place
the outputs of your training.
Be sure to use the same region
as where your data is stored
to get optimal performance.
Once you run this command,
your Python package
is going to get zipped up and
uploaded to the directory we
just specified.
From there, the
package will be run
in the cloud on the
machines that we
specified in the configuration.
You can monitor your training
job in the Cloud Console
by going to ML Engine
and selecting Jobs.
There, we will see a list of
all the jobs we've ever run,
including the current job.
You can also see a timer on
how much time the job has taken
so far and a link
to the logs that
are coming out of the model.
Our code exports the training
model to our cloud storage path
that we have provided
in the job directory.
So from here, we can easily
point to prediction service
directly at the outputs and
create a prediction service,
as we learned about Episode
4, Serverless Predictions
at Scale.
Using Cloud Machine
Learning Engine,
we can achieve
distributed training
without dealing with
infrastructure ourselves.
As a result, we can spend
more time with our data.
Simply package up the code,
add that configuration file,
and submit the training job.
If you want the
nitty gritty details
on TensorFlow's
distributed training model
check out this in-depth talk
from the TensorFlow Dev Center.
But for now, remember,
spend less time building
distributed systems and
more time with your data
by training your model using
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
I'm Yufeng Guo, and thanks for
watching this episode of Cloud
AI Adventures.
If you enjoyed it, please go
ahead and hit that like button.
And for more machine
learning action,
be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to catch future episodes
right when they come out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]